[Music]
our cells have two copies of all our
genetic information
meaning we have two copies of each gene
in every cell of our body
cancer can develop when cells acquire
mutations over time
both copies of a gene need to be mutated
for cancer to develop
gene mutations can be either inherited
or acquired
inherited mutations are called germline
mutations
and acquired mutations are called
somatic mutations
so many mutations or acquired mutations
happen when genes mutate over a person's
lifetime and are present in the tumor
they are not inherited or passed down to
children
somatic mutations may be caused by
environmental factors
habits diet or by chance
most cancers are caused by somatic
mutations
currently we cannot determine the exact
cause of somatic mutations in individual
patients inherited mutations or germline
mutations are typically passed down from
one of your parents
approximately five to ten percent of
cancers are due to inherited gene
mutations
[Music]